the next superhero offering from DC is
one you may not know a lot about so grab
your protective exoskeleton because this
is everything you need to know before
you go see Blue Beetle
and in order to get you as blue and
beetally as you can be we're gonna
answer five questions for you
free entry systems ready
so some of you might be asking who
exactly is Blue Beetle the history of
Blue Beetle actually dates all the way
back to 1939 when it was created by
Charles Nicholas whitekowski for Fox
Comics now back then BB was just a
mystery man in a simple costume named
Dan Garrett whose Powers came from a
sacred Scarab which is a beetle-shaped
amulet or stone popular in ancient Egypt
the rights were eventually sold to
Charlton Comics who turned him from a
mystery man into a person named Ted cord
now from there Blue Beetle scurried its
way over to DC Comics where Ted cord
eventually met his demise because then a
new guy a teenager named Jaime Reyes was
given powers from another Scarab
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me I may actually gain popularity
via a new Blue Beetle comic book and
then later is a key cast member on the
Animated Series Batman the Brave and the
Bold he actually was also on the list of
characters DC wanted to moviefy for
about 20 years so here we are finally
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist now when it comes to Blue's
Powers the Scarab gives him the ability
to produce a super strong exoskeleton
around his form and then produce various
tools and weapons based on whatever he
can imagine I mean pretty cool right I
wish I could do that with a blow dryer
whenever I'm in a hotel I feel like
they're just never that strong in hotels
nice choice
how exactly will this fit in with the
rest of the DC Universe I think I caught
a bus in half and I am here to tell you
it's actually a little bit up in the air
so the film was initially meant to be
part of a former regime's plan to
produce two mid-budget films per year
for the service formerly known as HBO
Max and they were actually supposed to
take place somewhere else in the
Multiverse away from the rest of the big
budget DC movies and the first two
projects put into motion were this and
Batgirl but as you may have already
heard DC's got new leadership in James
Gunn and Peter Safran and Batgirl was
actually shelved completely While Blue
Beetle was promoted to a full-on
theatrical release
yeah
so for right now it's kind of just
living in its own world within DC not
really a part of the dceu or guns but it
could very well be folded into that DCU
depending of course on what fans think
and more importantly how it does at the
box office
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
let's talk about who's in it now
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
starring in this one as Jaime Reyes
slash Blue Beetle is cholo mariduenia
best known for his role as Miguel on the
series Cobra Kai and this actually marks
his first ever film role now Hyman's
family in the film includes belisa
Escobedo as his sister Adriana Barraza
as his nana Damian Alcazar is his dad
and none other than George Lopez as his
uncle Rudy the director Angel Manuel
Soto said that building an authentic
Mexican-American family with a variety
of accents and experiences similar to
the comics it was actually a big part of
making this film and it's a big reason
why I'm so stoked for this because Blue
Beetle is actually the first solo film
for a Latino superhero my family that's
what makes me strong I actually got to
sit down with the all a team cast
including me which was a first so check
out that big ticket interview on
Fandango for some more Goods Angela and
I had a lot of conversations about like
this is for us as kids you know we
didn't there weren't a ton of examples
at least on the big screen so that's
where and how much we all love
superheroes it's like I know right
thanks back to the rest of the cast so
Susan Sarandon plays Victoria cord which
makes you wonder if the previous Blue
Beetle identity Ted Court I just told
you guys about could re-emerge to help
Jaime and rumor has it she's a villain
and helping Victoria do bad things is
Raul Trujillo as Kara packs the
indestructible man I mean bring on the
super villains no word yet on any cameos
from other DC characters and actors that
we already know but expect plenty of
references to other Heroes for sure
who said that
that's okay
at this point I'm sure you're like okay
okay Nas but what is this movie and
story actually about
create yeah that's more like it
now as far as the story those actors
will be portraying we know that Jaime
has been aged up just a bit so don't
expect any High School Shenanigans a la
Spider-Man instead we're gonna see Jaime
finding and bonding with a mysterious
alien Scarab as seen in the trailer and
from there he's gonna follow your
standard superhero Arc of learning his
powers and then learning a little bit
about being a hero and having just
learned that aliens are actually here on
Earth I kind of wish Blue Beetle existed
IRL anyways he'll also be fighting some
bad guys in this case cord Industries
who wants the Scarab for their own evil
purposes I mean the greed is endless in
these comics
okay let's talk about who made it
I advise me back away
now behind the scenes we got director
Angel Manuel Soto who I mentioned
earlier who actually previously helmed
the certified fresh Coming of Age drama
Charmed City Kings in 2020. and it kind
of feels like Blue Beetle could have a
similar theme for young Jaime and
putting the pen to the paper was writer
Gareth dunnid Alcazar who previously
wrote the Gina Rodriguez action flick
Miss Bala so we're talking a
coming-of-age expert director and an
action experience writer I mean I am
just loving that combo
you are a superhero cabron
okay friends that's everything you need
to know before you go see Blue Beetle in
theaters August 18th my name is Naz
Perez please let me know if you see a
blue beetle in real life and get your
phone out and you can actually scan this
QR code to get your tickets to the movie
now thanks for watching and be sure to
rate and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com